we've had the hateful eight and the
ridiculous six and now the big boss of
numerical westerns is set to return to
the big screen I'm Simon and this is
your Wild West news update the
star-studded remake of the classic
western the Magnificent Seven is
released later this year and the first
trailer for the film is now online the
film stars Denzel Washington as a gun
man who is hired to stop a group of
bandits from terrorizing a village he
puts together a gang of sharpshooters
they include Chris Pratt Ethan Hawke
Vincent D'Onofrio and beyond hyung Lee
the movie is directed by antoine fuqua
who previously directed Washington and
Hawk in the oscar-winning training day
the film is a remake of the 1960 movie
starring Steve McQueen and Yul Brynner
which was itself a retelling of Akira
Kurosawa's classic Japanese epic the
Seven Samurai speaking to USA Today
about his all-star cast foot were
revealed that Washington couldn't be
separated from his gun while the film
was in production he had it with him all
the time even when he wasn't on set he
said we have meetings and he'd be
spinning and twirling his gun while we
were talking he used to walk around his
house spinning guns go to restaurants
obviously people knew it was for his
character the Magnificent Seven rides
into cinemas on sep tember 23rd 2016 do
you think this Western is one remake too
many or are you excited to see Denzil
donning the full cowboy getup let me
know in the comments or come find me on
Twitter I'm at the j connaught thanks
for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot